one of the biggest reasons why aren't
repairs don't win because you don't
believe in yourself enough you need to
do the difficult things when it's hard
and you do it and you try and you keep
going that's when you feel pride about
yourself the more you live your life
faisel's what other people think if
you're gonna lose you're gonna lose the
first thing most people do after they
make a decision is a plan they
strategize
they tinker they sink and it's the worst
thing you can do there's two reasons why
you are being lazy need motivation watch
the top ten with believe nation
[Music]
I'm Evan Carmichael and here are my top
ten rules of success volume 7 enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one believe whether you believe you can
and you can't you're right right whether
you believe you can or you can't
you're right one of the biggest reasons
why aren't repairs don't win because you
don't believe in yourself enough that's
why why do I have this channel why is my
one word belief look look at the back of
Nina's sweater there it is right believe
believe that's it
it's so important there's so many you
guys are geniuses as so many geniuses
massively talented people out there with
amazing ideas that can change the world
but you don't go often crush because you
don't believe in yourself enough I think
the two biggest problems in the world
are one recognizing that you have
Michael Jordan level talent is something
believe in that you have something in
you that you're not meant to just wake
up and photocopy your life every day
working for somebody else just believing
that and to then believing in that
ability believing that you have Michael
Jordan level talent is something and
then when you found it believing in it
enough to chase it down every day to get
better because you need to beat on your
craft because it may be something that's
totally outside what is normal in your
family because it may be something way
outside what is normal for your culture
or your society or your community but
you have to go often do that crazy thing
and it's really hard to believe in
yourself enough to chase it down
especially when it's against what
everybody around you is saying and what
they believe and so great yes I need to
believe in myself amazing how do you do
it what's the process how do you gain
sub beliefs you need to eliminate the
negativity in your life and replace it
with belief so think about what are the
thoughts who are the people what are the
things around you that keep you where
you are to keep these negative patterns
in your head is it your parents is it
your friends is it the TV shows your
watching the media consuming like what
is it that is toxic that makes you feel
small and as much as possible
you either cuddle your life or reduce
the exposure if it's your mom who's
always on you and says you can't go be
an entrepreneur maybe you just don't
talk about your career with your mom
you put boundaries up I don't want to
talk about this there's other things
that we haven't come when you focus on
that stuff you lay out the ground rules
you make them respect you and you don't
talk about the things that you know is
gonna lead to conflict and for other
people you may need to just completely
cut them out of your life if it's your
best friend from growing up just because
you have friends in great Ford doesn't
mean she'd still be friends of adults a
lot of our friendships are out of
convenience you're with people just
because it's convenient to be with
people but you've grown apart and you
have to recognize that if somebody's
toxic around you you shouldn't be with
them and if you are its micro doses and
so you need to cut out a lot of the crap
in your life anything that's causing
negativity or self-doubt needs to be
eliminated from your life as much as
possible
great now you have a vacuum now you've
got this whole mothers that is this void
inside you great what do you do you fill
it up with positivity you fill it up
with beliefs my channels are pretty good
reasons I got this channel I got the
other channels you got three videos plus
a day coming out across my channels that
if you want more beliefs on your life
here's a great resource for you but
forget about me it's not about me it's
about you what makes you feel beliefs if
it's watching videos great if it's
listening to a podcast reading the book
doing an active service meditating
prayer whatever the thing is that helps
you feel belief do that every single day
fill yourself up with it I inject myself
with so much vitamin C belief I see
belief is ins injection and put it into
myself every day I have so much of it in
me that if somebody sneezes their
toxicity on me I'm not gonna get sick
because I'm surrounded with so much
belief that's what you need for your
life as well rule number two know your
why step number two is your why why do
you do what you do your purpose comes
from your pain your purpose comes from
your pain the thing that you will enjoy
the most in life is helping people who
currently are going through whatever you
massively struggled with think about the
biggest pain in your life whatever that
was growing up the biggest pain the
thing you'd never want to have to repeat
or go through again that pain that pain
the deep dark pain you wouldn't wish
upon your enemies that pain the worst
day of your life that pain
your greatest joy in life will be
helping people who are currently going
through that pain and getting them
through it that's it that's your purpose
for life that will never get old that
will be with you for life and so for me
starting up as an entrepreneur was my
biggest pain I felt worthless I was
making $300 a month I was suffering and
struggling and just felt defeated as a
human being that's why I love helping
out other entrepreneurs and that's gonna
be it for life that'll be my purpose for
life rule number three don't quit you
need to do things that make you proud of
yourself you need to do the difficult
things when it's hard and you do it and
you try and you keep going that's when
you feel proud about yourself when you
quit early even if everybody gives you a
logical reason for doing and say hey
it's okay don't worry about it quit you
should quit take it easy
but you know deep down inside yourself
you can't quit you have to do the work
that makes you feel proud because if you
face difficulties and then quit that's
what you're teaching yourself that's the
story inside your head and there's no
way you're gonna go off and accomplish
those big bad impossible and dream goals
of yours if you quit every time it gets
hard I had a guy come to my Columbus
workshop and he had a goal to do six
days a week cold showers it was Friday
night Saturday night was his day off
from cold showers it was Friday because
my workshopping says it's been winter
here in Columbus I'm at my girlfriend's
house all day today it's been freezing
bonanza I've been inside the house it's
been freezing all day I didn't do my
cold shower today I mean what should I
do
should I take my cold shower I said well
are you proud of the reason why not are
you proud of the reason that you're in a
cold house all day and so that's that's
good justification for you said no I'm
not proud of the reason great then you
have to do it you have to go take your
cold shower and after the workshop you
got home at 11:30 at night and he took
an Instagram video from from the waist
up getting into the cold shower and
freezing his face off and then I said
you have to go off and do it again
tomorrow too you've been oh Saturday's
your day off you have to get up and do
it again tomorrow just to show yourself
just to prove to yourself
what you're made of when it's difficult
and you try that's when you win that's
when you actually feel good about
yourself when it's difficult and you
keep going even if the results suck even
if past the 40% your results are
starting to decline you feel great about
yourself because you kept going but if
you quit as soon as it gets hard that's
what you're teaching yourself to do and
so I see entrepreneurs and leaders as
trees you're a tree your responsibility
as a tree is to eat poison carbon
dioxide right you eat poison you eat it
you grow from it and then you spit out
positivity and oxygen for the people
around you right for yourself and the
people around you you grow from it your
job was to eat adversity your job is to
eat judgment your job is to eat
difficulties and you grow from it and
then you create opportunities and
possibilities for yourself and the
people around you that's your job and so
the next time that you find yourself in
a difficult situation you want to quit
you want to give up you're at that mark
your brain wants to quit on you remind
yourself I'm a tree I'm a tree I'm gonna
grow from this this is my chance to get
better this is my chance to eat it to
grow from it and then create
possibilities for other people that's
your job if you want to be an amazing
leader and an amazing entrepreneur and
I'm cheering for you rule number four be
consistent lack of consistency is one of
the biggest reasons why entrepreneurs
fail one of the biggest reasons you're a
genius you have great ideas
you want to serve you know you're
capable of mark and you have these
moments of inspiration and moments of
boldness and moments of massive
productivity and focus and clarity but
it's not consistent and that's why most
entrepreneurs will lose because you
might crush it on a Saturday or Sunday
or Monday but then Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday you fall back down until
the next Saturday when you're up and
flying again it's not enough it's much
more about what you do every day you are
what you consistently do it's a huge
problem for entrepreneurs so let's fix
it number one if you are a part-time
entrepreneur if you
for someone else your part-time
entrepreneur you need to make sure that
every single day you're working on your
business every single day you have to
work on your business no matter what
even if it's for 15 minutes at night
every single day you cannot let momentum
die even just to show yourself that you
can even if it's a crazy long day and
your boss is yelling at you and you come
home and your spouse is angry and your
kids are sick even then you have to
spend 15 minutes on your business half
an hour on your business every single
day you cannot let the momentum die
don't disappoint yourself number two if
you're already full time when your
business great you could have CEO time
every day in your business CEO time time
where you spend being the CEO what does
that mean it's different for different
entrepreneurs but when you're working on
the business instead of in it if you
spend all time just working in the
business just putting out fires and ever
growing guess what you're never gonna
grow if you never have CEO time built
into your business you will never be a
CEO and so you need to make sure that
every day you have CEO time built into
your business a good maybe it's only
half an hour but in that half an hour
you're spending time growing your
company you're gonna start seeing
results and my last tip is I want you to
start your morning off powerfully I want
you to chart your start I want you to
have a morning routine that inspires you
that makes you feel bold most people
what do they do when they wake up first
thing you do is I hit the snooze button
what does that mean it means last night
you set a goal I'm gonna wake up at a
certain time right I'm gonna wake up at
6 a.m. 5 a.m. 7 a.m. 12 noon I don't
care what time you have to wake up you
set a goal you're gonna wake up and then
the very first thing that you do you
start your day every day just say I am
NOT gonna hit my goal today let's say
you start your day that's how most of
our America starts today
they say I'm not gonna hit my goal today
how do you think you're gonna go off and
have an amazing day and crush it and go
get your crazy big goals and ambitions
that you have as an entrepreneur when
you tell yourself and you reinforce it
every morning that you aren't I'm a
person who doesn't hit their goals you
got to change - you're gonna wake up
wake up when you see you gonna wake up
you know
bad when you say you're gonna get out of
bed that's step one then step two is
what is the morning routine that sets
you up for success most people wake up
like it's an accident they wake up you
check your phone
you respond into other people's and
vertices and their agenda for your time
that's not how you need to start your
day
successful people they own their morning
what does your morning look like and
we've all felt inspired and bold at some
point you felt you've been both been
inspired at some point in your life
great whatever that thing was it made
you feel both unstoppable inspired put
that into your morning routine maybe
this watching video if it's reading the
book maybe it's doing an act kindness
name is meditating maybe it's prayer
whatever is what's intention because
some of you have a morning routine
alrighty I'm talking to you you have a
morning routine already but you're not
brushing it every day you're not coming
out of that morning routine stealing
bold inspired consistently that's what
we're talking about consistency here
sometimes you just go through the
motions of your morning routine
sometimes you just pray but you're not
really connecting sometimes you just
want to video but you're making your
breakfast you're brushing your teeth you
not paying attention with intention do
your morning routine you must come out
of your morning routine every single day
feeling bold unstoppable and confident
if you did that if you woke up every day
on time like you say you're going to
you're knocking at the snooze button you
get out of bed and then you did the
thing that made you feel bold powerful
and unstoppable every single day holy
cow I guarantee you your life one year
from today will look dramatically
different than where you are right now
consistency is the game you are what you
consistently do and I want to see you
win also if you want to learn how to
have more confidence check out my 250
for confidence series it's free the link
is in the description below if you're
doing work that you love you're more
likely to follow through you're more
likely to do it because it doesn't feel
like work because you love doing it
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident rule number five
inoculate yourself against judgment the
more you live your life faisel's what
other people think if you're gonna lose
you gonna lose this you're an
entrepreneur you want to do crazy things
you have a bold ambitious vision for
what you want to accomplish in your life
you want to change the way something's
done in an industry right that's what we
want to do we want to change the world
you know what does a lot of people want
to protect the world the status quo they
want to protect the way things are done
you want to come in and shake up an
industry there's a lot of people who
want to protect that industry there's a
lot of people who don't like change
there's a lot of people who are so
afraid of seeing you be successful
because it means that they suck right
there's a lot of people who will in your
environment in your family your home
your friends people who they don't want
to see you win because it means they
suck because you've left them because it
means that they're not good anymore
because they judge themselves based off
of what everybody else is doing and a
lot of people have someone in their
family who went off and crushed it and
they tried it and then they failed
right they tried it so they may have had
some success and then they failed and
now nobody else around them is allowed
to be successful all they want to do is
pull everybody else down they took their
shot ultimately didn't work
you know they pull everybody else around
them they can't let that be you the more
you want to go off and have a bold
ambitious life for yourself
the more you're gonna have to learn to
what I call inoculate yourself against
judgment you need to inoculate yourself
against judgment the judgment of your
friends your parents the people around
you the general public social media
inoculate yourself against judgment as
long as you care what other people think
of you you will lose you will play small
forever you will not be living your
version of your life and so how do you
do it how do you not let yourself
against judgment here's how it goes any
time you feel your heart beating boom
boom boom bow bow bow your heart's
beating you're nervous you're scared
worried about what someone's gonna think
of you you have to do the thing you
train yourself
that's not an expression of you even if
you don't really care about doing that
thing or not you have to do it just to
train yourself something like this would
have been really difficult for me ten
years ago
you'll meet on the street it was really
hard I'll be worried about what people
think of me be worried about me standing
here San Francisco people walk you by
what do you think of me yelling into my
phone yelling into this microphone here
talking to you guys right here it's
scary and so because there's potential
judgement you get scared and then you
don't do the thing teach yourself to do
the thing if building in public sounds
like a scary thing to you like oh I
couldn't do that go do it
go find the busiest street that you can
find and then go make a video and here's
the thing expect it to suck you're not
gonna be great the first time you do
something that's okay expect a sock
expected to be the worst video ever made
and then tie yourself on the back and
say I did it
rule number six take action the first
thing most people do after they make a
decision is a plan they strategize
they tinker they think and it's the
worst thing you can do here's why you
make a bold decision you say I'm gonna
change my life I'm gonna go up and do
this crazy amazing thing and then you go
home and you think of all the ways that
you can happen and you start planning
and strategizes amazing you feel great
and then you wake up tomorrow and you're
a different person you wake up tomorrow
a different person and that person said
you can't do that you can't follow
through on that who are you to take on
that big idea and then nothing
nothing happens and so the solution
after you get immediate idea is actually
don't worry about planning even
imperfect action just action because you
need to build it into your nervous
system that you're the kind of person
who follows through because you need to
make some commitment so that by the time
you wake up tomorrow
you've committed to following through
that's the biggest problem I call the 2%
difference so what most people do is
they'll plan to 100% you get an idea you
got a plan you got no hope you got a
plan plan plan plan you got a plan all
the way to the end and it's amazing you
think about it it's such a great place
to live in as entrepreneurs as
perfectionist as over planners we love
living in that world don't worry about
planning the 100% instead find the 2%
difference what can you do right now
they get 2% of the way if you don't get
2% away immediately to action you will
never get to 100% of the way rule number
seven find your one word I think people
struggle with goals because they
struggle is self-awareness because they
don't know who they are and so they're
constantly adjusting the goals that they
have of themselves based off what other
people think of them and base of what
they see out in the media or an
Instagram or on YouTube they don't have
self-awareness you got to figure out
what your one word is what your most
important core value is who are you as a
human being I wrote a whole book on this
but just as a quick brainstorm
opportunity for you right now
think about what is your single most
important core value what is it you're
gonna pick one core values a human being
what is it to me it's belief I like
believing in people I need to believe in
people I hate negativity I hate toxic
people I hate the haters right I don't
want to be around people saying that you
can't do this I am the opposite I need
to believe and so already right there
already having that awareness of what
your one word is what your who is when
you figure that out it allows you to
make better decisions it means that if
you were in a work environment if I was
in a work environment where people
didn't believe in each other
I wouldn't I wouldn't be able to handle
it I would be frustrated be upset at
being angry and now I know why because
my one word is belief and so what is
your sin the most important core values
figure that out it's one of the most
important exercises you can ever do in
your life it's super helpful it's
valuable it's important you need to do
it otherwise you will never have clarity
over your goals remember eight do
difficult things self love comes from
doing difficult things
self-love comes from doing things that
you think are beyond your comfort zone
that you not keep full of doing and just
getting up and trying to do it that's
when you love yourself when something
that's easy and you win you actually
don't feel that great about yourself if
you were to go and run a race against
three-year-olds and you won great yeah
you won
you might even post about on Instagram
but you don't love yourself you don't
feel good about yourself because you
played small because it was easy because
you were expected to win because inside
your comfort zone when you play inside
your comfort zone always you don't love
yourself that comes from doing difficult
things that's how you build respect
that's how you build credibility that's
how you build self-love for you forget
about how other people respect and look
at you it's how you feel about yourself
that's the game and that comes from
doing difficult things so if you ran a
race against three-year-olds and you won
great who cares
you don't feel great about yourself
because you were expected to win but if
you ran a race against Usain Bolt and he
ran backwards on one leg he would still
probably destroy you but you should feel
great about yourself because you did the
thing when it was hard to do the thing
you might have lost his same boat but
you got in the race against him that's
how you build self-love when you tie
your self-respect when you tie your
self-worth when you tie yourself love to
the effort that you put in on a daily
basis that's when you start to win when
you tie yourself love to winning to
getting results you lose when you tie
yourself up to how many likes you have
on Instagram or views or subscribers on
YouTube you lose this about the effort
are you putting in the effort every day
because if you are proud of your effort
on a daily basis
I promise you you are going to crush it
but if you are only proud of yourself
when you win here's what's gonna happen
you're only gonna take on small things
you're gonna play small your entire life
because you're all gonna take on
projects that you have a pretty high
chance of winning that because that's
how you have love for yourself and
that's the losing game because you're
capable of more you're capable of doing
a lot more stuff you keep a little
playing a bigger game you're capable of
having a bigger impact
it's your duty if you do to love
yourself when you love yourself you'll
be able to spread that more and help
other people and so how do you love
yourself
it comes from doing difficult things it
comes from when your hearts beating like
crazy and you're scared and it's some
big project and you say I'm gonna try
I'm gonna try to do that scary thing I'm
gonna try to record a video in public
people may be watching you doesn't mean
your video has to be great okay so it's
gonna suck but you tried I usually feel
great about yourself rule number nine
have big dreams
people aren't lazy they just don't have
dreams that inspire them they default to
thinking I'm a lazy person I don't have
ambitions I don't know what I want to do
in life I'm just I'm just a loser no you
just don't have a dream that makes you
want to go off and do something and
until you figure that out you're gonna
be in this constant cycle of feeling
like a loser it's one of the most common
questions that I get asked on my IG
streams I go live every single day and
Instagram at least right now while I'm
on my tour and every single day I get
asked some variation of Evan unli see
how do I get out of it Evan I'm
procrastinating how do I get out of it
one you don't call yourself a lazy
person there's no such thing as a lazy
person if you are procrastinating or
you're being lazy right you are being
lazy doesn't mean that you are a lazy
person there's two reasons why you're
doing it there's two reasons why you are
being lazy one you don't have a dream
that's big enough you don't have some
that inspires you you don't want to get
out of bed in the morning if I was an
accountant I would be a really lazy
accountant I would hate my life not to
knock accountants it's just not for me
if I was a video editor I would be I
would be lazy I would hate my life I
don't want to be a video editor I don't
want to be an accountant actually
there's most things in the world that I
don't want to be and if you force me to
do that I would be lazy that's 95
percent of America I think 95 percent of
America wakes up and drive to a job that
they hate and then they're lazy there
but they have dreams they have ambitions
you have Michael Jordan level talent at
something you just have to find it and
so if you don't know what that thing is
then it's your duty to go off and
explore you test you try you see you say
yes to a lot of stuff like this is the
most important thing that you need to
figure out in your life if you don't
know what your dream is you have to go
off and try things
just like you won't get married until
you go on dates you won't get married to
an idea until you go on dates until you
try it until you say yes and the acid
test is did I like it don't want to go
back this is fill me up that I enjoy the
process of it can I see myself doing
this and having fun because when you're
having fun doing the work that's when it
will fill you up that's when you won't
be lazy and there has been times and all
your lives where you felt that we felt
the joy the energy the ambition the
drive and so you need to capture that
and say yes and find what it is that
your big dream is and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is surround yourself with good
people you're trying to change yourself
to fit into a social circle because you
feel you're not good enough you feeling
not good enough you feel they won't be
accepted otherwise you feel you have no
friends
the reality is you're different you're
weird that's amazing that's great and
it's never been easier to find your
tribe it's never been easier to find
people who build you up who support you
who cheer you on
who wants similar things to you and
until you find that group you're always
gonna feel like an outcast you're always
gonna feel like a fake you're always
gonna feel like you're trying to impress
people who you don't like but what's
your alternative because you have no
friends otherwise and so here's a
process you can use to follow to help
you be around the right people and start
building the life you want step 1
eliminate negativity think about the
people in your life right now who just
make you feel low who suck your energy
who you don't feel good about yourself
when you're around
we just make you feel oh and you don't
want to be around them anymore
maybe those are some friends that you
grew up with and that they're not your
friends anymore
and that's okay I think a lot of us stay
in relationships based out of
convenience just because you want to
elementary school with somebody doesn't
mean that you should still be their
friend now you're just in that
relationship out of convenience you guys
have grown apart and you need to accept
it if you're around they go to people
like that or maybe it's your parents
then either limit your exposure to them
or cut off access completely you know if
it's a friend who's toxic don't be
around that person anymore if it's
people who make you feel less than don't
be around those people anymore if it's
your parents or it's a close friend that
you still have some connection to but
there's just one thing that when you
talk about makes you feel bad don't talk
about those things anymore if you're
talking to your parents and they don't
like your arms burial
don't talk about that stuff anymore put
boundaries up because there's still
enough of a connection around other
things hopefully if not maybe you don't
want to be talking to those people but
if there's enough of a connection still
with your mom with your dad
talk about that stuff and put boundaries
around talking about your career because
you know what's gonna cause controversy
people to get upset and negativity so
step one is you need to eliminate the
people or limit access to you from the
people who are causing you to feel bad
about you there's no way you're gonna
create amazing things build an amazing
business if you're around negative
people who bring you down all the time
it's just not possible so step one
eliminate those people or limit access
step two now you've got this whole
you've got a gap in your schedule you've
got extra time now on your hands and now
what you want to do is fill it with
positivity and I see two paths here one
you want to start trying to hang out
with people who feel the same way you do
and so look for entrepreneur events look
for meetup groups look for conferences
I've coming to your town I'm here making
this video in Las Vegas at every stop
along the tour that I've been doing over
the past X number of days 45 days or so
we got a 45 more days ahead it's been
amazing to see the connections that
people make by being in a room of other
successful entrepreneurs who have the
same mindset of wanting the guac and
accomplish something great somebody just
DM me two days ago of people who met in
my Los Angeles event they had never
known each other before they met at my
Elli event and then they went running
together so they went running and caught
the sunrise together in LA that's what
I'm talking about when you start going
to events where you start meeting people
who feel the same way you do want to
build similar things as you are it just
lifts your energy so much the finally
holy Cal there's other people who
believe the same thing I do I want to
hang around those people more and so say
yes look at what events are happening in
your city and go to them some might be
free some might be paid depends on what
your budget is but go to them start
meeting people say yes be around that
environment because you're not getting
that right now with your parents your
friends the circle that surrounds you
immediately you need to step out and
start hanging around these people and
start going to events maybe only meet
one person at that event that's okay
that's a start surround yourself with
those people now I've got a special
bonus clip from myself on how to learn
how to communicate that I think you
could enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions do
you watch the video now it's time to
take action here we go question number
one
what's a difficult thing that you will
commit to doing this week
number two what is your one word and
number three what helps make you believe
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have and I think a lot of businesses
fail because the entrepreneur cannot
communicate well and if they even are
sharing their ideas they are not
convincing enough and so a lot of great
ideas die you could have the next
greatest idea that can change the world
it's sitting up here but because you
can't articulate it because you can't
share it because you can't communicate
it well because you're not convincing
enough to the people around you it will
never take off the idea will die within
you and I hate that I hate that because
building a business getting the thing
that's out here out into the world is
greater than one person no matter how
much of a genius you are to build a
business you need a team you need a team
of people to help you go far and you
also need to convince the media and
customers and partners and suppliers of
what you have is amazing if you are the
only one who thinks that your idea it is
amazing and you can't communicate or
convince anybody else of that then
you're done denied idea dies within you
and I think unfortunately that's a lot
of entrepreneurs so Jordan has three of
his tips I'm gonna give you three of
mine on how to be a convincing
communicator step number one is have a
powerful opinion you have an opinion
what is it that you are trying to say
make it mean something to yourself and
to me and make that the first sentence
of every piece of content that you make
if you're doing a video that's your
first sentence you're doing an Instagram
post put it in there you're doing a
LinkedIn post an email a newsletter like
put it in there you lead with your
powerful opinion on what is wrong with
the world
or what your viewpoint on XYZ topic is
make it mean something to me make me
care so I'm talking about communication
how important it is for entrepreneurs a
powerful opinion would be something like
you need to learn how to communicate in
your business or you will never get that
idea that's in your head out into the
world and your idea will die inside you
that's an opinion where lots of people
might say something like so if you want
to learn how to build a successful
business and maybe take your idea to the
next level I think maybe you should
focus on trying to improve how you speak
and communicate like it's so long
it has lots of filler words you use
words like maybe and potentially and
someday and one day and I wish and we
instead of I like affirmative stop
worrying about what people's reactions
are gonna be and speak your truth always
lead with a powerful opinion tip number
two is emotional commitment this is
where a lot of entrepreneurs really fall
down you've got your pals in opinion you
know what you stand for you know what
you're trying to communicate but when
you get in front of a camera or when you
get down to writing it doesn't sway
people it's not emotional enough you
could be saying all the best words when
you get in front of a camera to make a
video but because you are talking in a
very boring very non exciting manner and
because you're so worried about saying
the perfect words that you are
memorizing something or you are looking
at your script or trying to read from a
teleprompter nobody is going to care or
listen to you you need to have emotional
commitment you need to feel the thing
and how important it is while you are
saying it for me I'm envisioning all of
you I'm envisioning all the
entrepreneurs that I've worked with who
have these are amazing ideas and they
never get them out because they can't
communicate and even though I'm sitting
here in an office by myself and there's
nobody around
to connect with I'm just talking to a
camera I'm trying to channel you I'm
trying to channel all the people that
I've connected with and seen and I want
to make sure that your business does
well and communicating is so important
as part of that which is why I'm doing
this video and hopefully the care the
love the energy comes through in the
content that I make and so sales and
convincing people not enough against
what they want but in a positive way
like this is something that you guys can
get together on is about the energy
transfer you are not just selling a
concept or an idea you are transferring
energy whoever is more confident wins
whoever is more convincing wins and it's
usually from whoever believes in their
thing more if you absolutely believe in
your thing and that this is right and
it's for them when they need to do this
thing because it's in their best
interest not because they're just trying
to sell something down their throat but
you really really really really care and
if they feel that care as opposed to
just words that you're saying that's how
you bring them on board it's great to
have the best words but more important
is the emotional commitment that you
have behind them so the best test with
any of this is watch back some of your
content and watch back your videos read
your newsletters see the copy on your
website look at the story that you wrote
about yourself and why you started this
business does it get you excited it's
like boom boom boom boom boom boom like
yes that's right that's why I do this
thing or did you watch it and you get
bored if you get bored and it doesn't
get your heart beating and do it again
do it again and do it again and do it
again and do it again you will be one of
your best critics you will be funny your
harshest critics and so we know if you
look over your content and get to the
point where you say wow yeah I'm really
proud of that that's when you start to
win and tip number three is racist aches
just make it more important if you want
to move people so often we're focused
just on the tactics the strategies
here's the five things that you need to
do and people say yeah yeah
great I love those five things awesome
they write them down and then they never
do anything about it you need to raise
the stakes you have to make it more
important you have to make me feel the
pressure that if I don't do this thing
that you want me to do terrible things
will happen right so if I talk about how
important communication is me just
saying communication is really important
as an entrepreneur here are the three
ways to do it it's known as powerful as
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have because if you don't learn how
to communicate your idea and get it out
there that idea will die inside you and
your mission will never be realized and
listen that paints a dark picture that's
going to an extreme and the idea is not
to have hyperbole and make things bigger
than they are but that's a real case for
tons of entrepreneurs that if they do
not learn how to communicate properly
their ideas will never get out there and
their idea will die inside them and so
your goal if you want to move people is
to make them realize how big this thing
is for them if they don't take action
you're the expert you know where the
road is going you see their future if
they continue down that path they don't
see that future they don't understand it
it's your job to help them see where
this current path of action is gonna
lead them and if they make the tweak
they make the change to take your
recommendations where it could go raise
the stakes make it more important make
them feel that it's more important and
it actually starts with you feeling that
this message is insanely important
if you want more Evan check out the top
50 rules video my teammate the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there the people who win work
the hardest because they love what they
do I hate spending money till and making
money if you do not have money